allora adesso li vedo un grande sforzo
adesso dobbiamo stare un attimo attenti
perché si parla di paura e la paura e
non vanno ma sottolinea non va preso
sottogamba la paura è qualcosa che ci
tenevi v2 false che non ci dicono molto
lonergan il 25 gennaio del 1998
questi due americani due anni lei 29
decidono di andare a fare una
esplorazione una un'immersione nella
meravigliosa barriera corallina
australiana della costa nord ovest si
imbarcano su una si imbarcano su una
barca che si chiama out lane e si
mettono si divertono conta provvedono
polipi vedono tutto quello che
sott'acqua una barriera corallina un
certo punto emergono dall'acqua e
improvvisamente si accorgono che la
barca non c'è più
l'autore igino nell'intorno inizialmente
loro probabilmente la prendo come uno
scherzo che abbia troppo tornano
logicamente la moglie se la prendeva del
marito questo non c'è dubbio che cosa
succede anche se una barca di abbandona
e comunque colpa del marito
e allora piano piano però cosa succede
succede che si rendono conto che sono
veramente in un mare di
continuate voi piacere perché lo posso
dire parolacce comincia in loro un senso
di paura probabilmente di spavento di
panico di angoscia poi dopo vedremo che
tutte queste parole sono importanti
quelli della barca dell'auto range non
si rendono conto che queste due persone
sono rimaste dentro un oceano a migliaia
di chilometri della costa in un
pomeriggio di un giorno di gennaio
voi adesso ho fatto lo sforzo cercare di
immaginare voi stessi in quella
situazione
immaginate come l'avete possibile di
comunicare immaginate che sto arrivando
la notte immaginate che sotto di voi non
ci sono dei teneri pesciolini rossi ma
ci sono per esempio delle meduse
straordinarie come leggere le brawn
jellyfish che sono le mete più velenose
ci sono mondo e soprattutto i nostri
amatissimi squali dopo due giorni il 27
gennaio una della barca dice marco
iconici che siano fatti due americani
fanno il conto e vedono che si sono
dimenticati di quelle due persone
queste due persone sono rimaste lì da
quel momento in poi senza che nessuno li
abbia cercati logicamente non hanno
fatto una buona figlia molto
probabilmente a distanza di due
settimane nella pancia di uno squalo
trovano la macchina fotografica di
coniugi lonergan ora non si sanno che è
successo a questi due sicuramente non
sono ancora in viaggio di nozze da
allora è hollywood hanno approfittato
questa idea per mettere in scena un film
che forse avete visto open water del
2003 perché vi racconto questa storia
perché in questa storia ci sono tutti
gli elementi della poca tutti e ora li
vedremo tutti quanti insieme e cercherà
anche di capire perché però ci può
essere un piacere della povera è il
primo elemento che vi dico il primo
elemento che per me è fondamentale e che
da paura un grande carburante per
raccontare storie
noi tutti vogliamo sentire delle storie
noi tutti siamo affascinati da storia
che hanno a che fare con la paura
immaginate i cavernicoli i nostri nostri
avi simpaticissimi belli pelosi un po
più penosi di m questa gente che aveva
paura di tutto logicamente no perché che
ne so uscirono usciva da moglie per
andare a fare la spesa o andare a
prenderla da mangiare prendendo una
pianta poi va bene in alto usciva al
padre e cadeva un macigno in testa a
uscire al figlio arrivava un simpatico
animale selvatico solo portarla via
le intermedie di un cavernicolo e
ritorno e 25 anni
io sarei a un matusalemme perché per
loro quindi la paura a quei tempi è
qualcosa di pervasivo di sempre
esistente e cosa facevano per vincere la
propria si riunivano un po non fuoco e
raccontano delle storie perché la storia
era un modo attraverso il quale vincere
o meglio elaborare questa paura quelli
più audaci
cominciamo a disegnare sulle pareti e
infatti le scene nelle caverne o quelle
della pittura rupestre quasi sempre è
una pittura che racconta di caccia o
comunque di scena dell'orrore
ora tutti quanti voi state cercando di
immaginare cosa hanno vissuto i coniugi
lonergan in quel momento
immaginate la paura degli squali la
propria della notte che arriva al freddo
l'imposta di mangiare stare con la
propria moglie con il proprio marito in
eterno nel mare cosa c'è di più
spaventoso ragione lei mi guarda e non
cartonato nella persona e e questo è
quello che facciamo ciò che dissi mi
chiamo nella pura degli altri però quasi
mai riflettiamo sul kickoff è la paura
davvero
e cominciamo con il dire che tutti
quanti noi abbiamo una grande paura
della paura
pensate ai la paura per noi hanno
portato il segno di debolezza e qualcosa
che deve essere eliminato a tutti i
costi mentre pensavo a come fare questo
mio auspicio in questi giorni sono stato
al mare alcuni giorni fa non in alto
mare logicamente reduce dalla storia che
conoscevo e e mentre ero lì arriva c'era
un padre con un figlio
questo figlio non vuole entrare in acqua
paura non degli squali tipo se aveva
paura e la paura e ha sentito il padre
dire queste parole e dai giovando fare
la femminuccia entra al di là del
commento
chiaramente maschilista c'è però
qualcosa di molto potente in questa e in
questa frase e cioè il concetto che
avere paura è una debolezza avere paura
è qualcosa di cui dobbiamo tenere
tant'è che nel linguaggio e nei
utilizziamo diciamo che cosa vincere la
paura sconfiggere la paura battere la
paura non avere paura
gli eroi sono questi cazzuti che non
hanno paura di niente
ora dobbiamo porre di lavoro ha
continuamente ma la paura è così
malvagia la paura è così tremenda per
ognuno di noi cerchiamo di capire
innanzitutto alla radice
andiamo alla radice delle parole perché
le proprie non sono tutte quante uguali
paura angoscia spavento terrore timore
sono tutte ste parte della stessa
famiglia ma solo cose diverse una
dall'altra
sapete da dove deriva la parola paura
dal latino tuttavia dalla torre del
greco
ma la paura deriva dalla parola latina
punta che pavor che a sua volta chiede
un'altra parola molto molto antica che
va a dio e cioè io vengo percorso io
vengo abbattuto pensate che paura e
pavimento hanno la stessa radice
pavimento e ciò che viene percorso ciò
che viene battuto e poi noi abbiamo
paura siamo atterriti cioè veniamo
buttati a terra
questa è la paura che diversa poi da
quello che vedremo troppo ma la paura
non è stata sempre di debolezza ora è
stata sempre qualcosa che dovevamo
tenere coloro che ne capivano tanto di
di tutto e cioè i greci classici greci
greci quelli ora è fatto problemi di
anche di economia ma quelli quelli
classici conoscevano istanze delle
parole il senso delle cose e ne hanno
fatto addirittura un dio ma per
qualsiasi cosa logicamente però la paura
è una di queste
e come si chiamava il chiude la propria
si chiamava phobos da cui poi info piano
focus che poi in latino i latini
chiamarono il diverso molto a cui anche
timor fungo e così via e powerline che
comunque questo dio focus anche la sua
genesi
interessante lui sapete di che il figlio
è figlio del dio della guerra ares il
dio dell'amore addirittura è la destra
la dea dell'amore afrodite come è
possibile mettere il primo capiamo e la
paura fia della guerra perché all'epoca
faceva guerra per qualsiasi cosa
i greci antichi erano peggio di salvini
e de luca adesso cioè si incazzano per
questo si cofano combattimento tra di
loro i greci antichi quindi abbiamo
paura della della guerra e per questo
capiamo che phobos insieme a dei most
per il fratello che significa terrore
era uno dei bumper i geni era figlio
anche dell'amore
in che senso secondo alcuni studiosi che
credo sia molto interessati a questa
teoria le cose abbiamo più poveri qual è
la cosa che più si spaventi in assoluto
i genitori lo fanno e la paura di
perdere
con lui che amiamo di più o colei che
abbiamo di più
nostro figlio e nostro figlio o anche
per chi è innamorato perdere il proprio
amato questa è la più grande paura e
questo trovarsi improvvisamente in un
buio oceanico senza il nostro amore
accanto ma anche semplicemente il
ragazzo vorrebbe ragazza non ha paura di
queste trovarsi improvvisamente solo
allora fosse al senso che phobos sia
figlio del dio della guerra e della dea
dell'amore
forse assenza ma i greci non temevano
phobos come noi temiamo la paura
addirittura focus era un dio che si
pregava gli spartani gente posta erano
adoratori del dio focus prima di andare
in guerra andava in questo tempio in
tempi molto particolare contornato di
aceri rossi perché era il segno della
paura l'albero della paura questi
spartani andavano e spartiti
in particolar modo cioè la casta più
fortunati dei guerrieri andavano dal mio
focus perché il dio phobos fosse con
loro in guerra
quindi lo adoravano non lo temevano la
paura quindi e questo è il primo senso
di questo mio intervento è qualcosa che
possiamo avere al nostro fianco
qualcosa che ci può aiutare tant'è che
molti dittatori che molti recenti
preferiscono essere temuti che
rispettate perché in quel in quella
forza del tumore
c'è una potenza
la paura è diversa dal panico conoscete
la prova panico ben sapete che panico
dinner da colui che sa che fare compagni
dio pan chi era giovanni il tuo pane che
questo simpatico personaggino metà uomo
metà capro dio delle greggi tra l'altro
ha una funzione molto particolare ci fa
capire che cosa per noi il panico che
cosa il panico e quando lo abbiamo paura
di qualcosa che neanche sappiamo che
cosa è qualcosa che emerge dal buio e
che lo abbiamo ben capito che cos'è il
panico e quello che durante il comic ci
ha costretto andare nelle nei
supermercati e svaligiare tutto ciò che
potremo svaligiare trend e le pennette
lisce questo è il panico ma il panico da
dove deriva cerchiamo di capire le
parole perché le parole sono tutto porti
penso che molti dicono ok sono soltanto
parole ma le parole sono tutto è una
ingenuità pensare che i fatti siano
dalla parte le parole dall altro i
classici lo sapevano bene pensate che la
parola etimologia quando la radice delle
parole e da un'altra parola che
significa etimos che significa verità
cioè l'etimologia è la ricerca della
verità che è sempre nelle parole allora
che succede
all'inizio dei tempi succede che questo
dio pazzesco e krònos il gioco del tempo
perché ha sentito una profezia
nel quale si diceva che un figlio un
giorno lo avrebbe tradito e ucciso cosa
fa comincia a prendere tutti i figli
della moglie rea e conosce divorarli uno
dopo l'altro è molto bello il senso del
tempo c'è timore alle cose kronos timore
i suoi figli però uno riesce a salvarsi
e zeus grazie alla madre che la mette da
parte e l'ho fatta questo 0 si fa
vomitare il padre e che escono dalla sua
bocca in grecia sono molto corporali
della fabbrica escono altri figli tra
cui poseidone ad e insieme si mettono a
fare squadra e combattono contro kronos
ai titani però la situazione molto
complicata
questi sono davvero tosti i danni sono
la gente gigantesca veramente potente
allora arriva in soccorso pan cosa fa un
la in maniera spaventosa è una caverna
da cui non viene visto e i titani
terrorizzati si bloccano e a quel punto
zeus e i suoi fratelli bello che poi
somiglia molto rock ei suoi fratelli mai
zeus sui fratelli riesce a battere i
gitani guardate allora il panico panda
cosa ha dato a bloccare è qualcosa che
arriva da da un punto che non conosciamo
tant'è che nella mitologia banda è un
tipo che dorme quasi semplice stare un
po come molti mariti pomeriggio della
domenica dopo che hanno visto la partita
fanno li cambi tra e quello voglio
essere disturbati e quando qualcuno
arriva a disturbarli giusta la caverna
della foresta nulla e la gente scappa o
si blocca questo è il panico capanna ma
c'è ancora un altro tipo di paura e
l'angoscia la coscia
viene ancora da un'altra parola che
l'aquila dice anche una parola è una
radice indoeuropea è diventata il ladino
angelo che significa a soffocare che
significa schiacciare tenere cioè far
perdere il fiato di voi è mai capitato
la notte si sentisse un grande peso
sullo stomaco e non solo i peperoni vi
assicuro è il co.co.pro avete mangiato è
una sorta di c'è qualcosa che non va via
gli eco fa serie b toglie il respiro
nella mitologia della puglia e della
basilicata diretta con le mal ombre
nella invece nella nella mitologia
indoeuropea si chiamano i malas questi
questi figuri molto particolari guardate
questo è un dipinto molto bello nel 1782
di un pittore svizzero svizzeri non
vanno soltanto formaggio cioccolate
anche quanto e bancano se fanno molte
cose a cui anche grandissimi dipinti
come questo questa è la rappresentazione
più bella dell'angoscia un demone
notturno sulla donna che sembra priva di
vita perché ha perso il fiato e guardate
sullo sfondo c'è un cavallo agli occhi
bianchi a due motivi per cui se quel
cavallo li cosa che mi interessa però
sarebbe bello a che fare un po di
analisi dei dipinti dove molte volte
contenuta la verità in questo dipinto
quel cavallo ha una doppia significata
innanzitutto nella mitologia della fine
della fine del xviii secolo o il massimo
del terrore era rappresentato da da da
da streghe e cavalli neri che arrivano
nella notte però c'è un altro motivo in
inglese una cavallina m
meir e il cubo che cos'è in inglese
nightmare e cioè possiamo dire la
cavalla della notte tradotta in maniera
molto letterale
fra l'altro equa avuto su questo dipinto
l'angoscia a che fare tantissimo con il
senso dell'incubo e io voglio riportarvi
ancora una volta senza delle parole si
deve chiesti cosa significa
ma che questo grido al latino in cu dare
giacere sopra stare sopra e quindi
schiacciare perciò virus t buy che senso
schiaccia le difese immunitarie questo
fa ad oggi abbiamo visto diversi modi di
intendere la paura abbiamo la paura
abbiamo il panico abbiamo un angoscia
che è un senso di soffocamento e
qualcosa che non sappiamo spiegarci
pensate a quei due alle due persone che
abbiamo lasciato dell'oceano tombe dei
lane
a un certo punto dopo l'iniziale panico
e cioè non sanno cosa c'è sotto di loro
non sanno cosa c'è di fronte a loro non
sanno cosa la notte porterà però piano
piano al panico subentra un'altra forma
di paura e cioè l'angoscia e l'angoscia
qualcosa che ti soffoca qualcosa che
bene il tempo tutti noi probabilmente in
un momento della vita
abbiamo sentito quell'angoscia durante
la quarantena abbiamo cominciato semmai
scherzando cazzeggiando abbiamo
continuato poi un certo punto ad avere
un po paura siamo lì nel panico
a un certo punto è arrivata l'angoscia
questa sensazione di dover uscire di
casa perché stavamo soffocando questa è
la nostra aveva finito
il ragazzo è allora che vi devo dire che
quando ci viene dalle parole della fine
della paura
a noi piace in che senso piace io vado
molto spesso nelle molto spesso nelle
scuole e scrivo coltissimo molti romanzi
per ragazzi incontro tantissimi ragazzi
e quando chiede ragazzi con saic rose
che vi piace di più sono le storie che
mi piacciono di più tutti quanti
invariabilmente di quello che sono le
storie di terrore le storie d'orrore nel
mio intervento ha dovuto spiegarmi
perché piacciono queste storie di poker
di non so quanti minuti ancora ditte per
sopportarmi quante ne avete quanti
ancora c'è lui vivo anche lei è perfetta
ma post quando non ce la fate più
traghettare le mascherine
oppure mi di nate qualcosa io capisco
però devo dirvelo perché è bella la
paura altrimenti nel mio intervento
l'assenza abbiamo ci sono diversi i
motivi per cui la paura ci piace il
primo motivo ora vado più velocemente
il primo motivo è che la paura ci fa
crescere la paura è uno dei modi
attraverso il quale noi diventiamo più
adulti c'è uno studioso molto
interessante che si chiama cladis sparks
e lavora all'università di pur di un ora
di rito ha preso con il classico di
versione del kaiser che nessuno conosce
invece non i soldi per dio e
l'università detta la cura degli
astronauti è la cioè la l'università
dove vengono sono stati allevati più
grandi astronauti della storia
dell'umanità aguiari nostra meno sulla
luna quindi agenti che con la paura a
che fare questo blend sparks a dalla
fretta di studi ha capito la cosa
fondamentale e cioè che molto
probabilmente la bocca e il nuovo rito
di passaggio degli esseri umani
una volta quando nelle tribù un uomo un
ragazzino doveva diventare adulto che
faceva affrontava delle prove di paura
gli spartani per esempio lo facciamo
queste queste giornate queste settimane
i boschi per pc
e per dimostrare il proprio coraggio ora
purtroppo ai nostri bambini la cosa più
coraggiosa che fanno affari mangiare il
panino la sera che contenga una patatina
fritta
quindi viste con il suo più riti di
passaggio come fanno i ragazzi a
effettuare questo scarto scelgono delle
storie che li mettono in sfida
e allora i gioielli del terrore allora a
film di paura libri di paura perché lì
loro trovano in qualche modo il senso di
una sfida il senso di una crescita se
non affrontiamo le paure noi cresciamo
mai
tant'è che le persone che sono più
regredite sono coloro che sono in base
sono circondate da paure che non
riescono mai a vincere queste gole
motivi ma un altro motivo a che fare
addirittura con il cervello cioè quella
che si chiama brain mac e cioè che
significa noi come esseri umani cosa che
ci crede davvero degli animali il fatto
del lobo frontale è incredibilmente
cresciuto e quella parte del cervello
che permette adesso di capire quello che
sto dicendo e cioè il linguaggio e cioè
roba complessa sapete quando si attiva
tantissimi lobo frontale quando in
macchine alla moglie avesse un marito fa
cosa stai pensando e lì il terrore
assoluto
l'angoscia lo spavento e vedo che il
signore infatti dice sì quello era vera
angoscia per quei momenti in cui lobo
frontale di ritrovare qualcosa di
intelligente da dire
tutte le grandi problemi ancora tutto in
quei momenti mentre andrà quindi noi
continuamente durante tutta la giornata
stiamo lì a pensare siamo lì a a
riflettere e sapete perché le donne sono
meglio degli uomini aifo questo sono
convintissimo perché secondo gli studi
di biologia e lobo frontale delle donne
più sviluppati rispetto a quello
dell'uomo
quindi sono capaci di giovane tipi de il
meraviglioso con successo della signora
hai visto tu hai visto che te lo dicevo
che l'uomo frontale e lui distrutto da
questa da questa questa evidenza della
scienza allora che facciamo durante la
giornata a mettere in pausa questo
ronzio quotidiano
alcuni di voi non so chi di voi forse
non meditazione prestazione un modo
straordinario per mettere in pausa ma
non tutti lo fanno i videogame i libri
ei racconti di paura sono un modo
attraverso il quale fare un'operazione
di brain mac e cioè di rottura di questo
non zio continuo in che modo perché
interviene una parte del cervello che si
chiama amigdala e cioè piccola mandorla
che si occupa di cose molto interessanti
si occupa di far suonare i campanelli
d'allarme
quando c'è qualcosa di interessante per
esempio adesso passa da qui roberto
bolle
tutte le ragazze e le donne le signore
anche la signora in passato roberto
bolle smette di pensare è la bibita la
manga segnali forza da che sta roberto
bolle roba del genere e cioè attiva
dopo il processo e che faremo sessualità
per esempio ma anche quando abbiamo
paura di qualcosa e l'amigdala che si
prende il comando e quando la mini dalla
prende il comando il lobo frontale è
finito allora trovato il film horror che
succede scena del terrore cervelo smette
di pensare perché è l'amica della
carriera e nel comando ci posso dare le
mani ci fa battere il cuore più forte
cicardi la voglia di muoverci di a
scappare e in quel momento abbiamo messo
fine al ronzio costante del lobo
frontale c'è anche sono tantissimi altri
monotipo in cui sto bene la paura anche
perché un'altalena ormonale la paura da
un veramente un piacere fisico dopo che
abbiamo superato una paura sapete cosa
non la paura scatena adrenalina cioè
questo un po
eppure che batte money money sudaticcia
roba del genere voglia di scappare
quanto però abbiamo superato la paura
quando ce l'abbiamo fatta
il cervello ci inonda di dopamina e
questo neurotrasmettitore meravigliosa
le comunali
facciamo nostra parolaccia è come un e
con una botta di vita c'era ecco diciamo
così lo devo dire l'orgasmo del cervello
quindi quando il giorno un videogame e
abbiamo superato un livello sono fatta o
quando capiamo che la persona uccisa nel
film non siamo noi ma è lui
esultiamo per la sua morte perché mors
tua vita mea in quel momento la dopamina
gironda e siamo strafelici veramente
allora da dove sempre stato molto tempo
avevo tantissime cose ancora da dire non
le dirò di con importi nissim a cosa
riferiamo un attimo a tom eileen
portiamolo nel in quel mare cosa avevo
fatto tutto quel tempo si sono hanno
immaginato l'immaginazione e il più
grande carburante della paura quando
abbiamo paura immaginiamo creiamo delle
scene creiamo delle storie che hanno
mini hanno una trama all'inizio uno
sviluppo per un finale come chianti cui
ha paura di tifare sull'aereo quando sei
una flat facciamo un piccolo film io
tranquillo salgo sull'aereo metto
l'altro nella cappelliera l'aereo parte
lario si blocca l'aereo cadde io muoio
queste perché la trama sono dei
personaggi personaggio però sono io
avevo già ve lo scrivo ci sono dei
conflitti all'interno il buono contro il
male e c'è soprattutto quella quella
parola magica che chiunque di noi scrive
sa che è fondamentale
e poi è quello che ci fa andare avanti
delle serie tv quando finisce una
puntata e ci incazziamo perché vogliamo
vedere cosa succede dopo
e poi oppure quando ci diamo una pagina
di un libro
ci piace molto tenteremo non possiamo
sapere le poi già paura crea questo e
poi continuo
quando noi impareremo che la paura si
può chiamare anche fare storie e saremo
noi gli attori di quelle storie la paura
scomparirà
ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]